tejerías sigue despertándose de una
pesadilla casas totalmente cubiertas de
barro y una destrucción todavía
incalculable marcan el panorama de la
ciudad del estado venezolano de aragua
después del deslizamiento de tierra que
ha cobrado la vida de decenas de
personas algunos vuelven para reconocer
sus hogares por ahora Dale gracias a
Dios porque estoy viva y tengo salud
empezar de cero miren lo que tengo al
menos 1200 funcionarios Fueron
desplegados por el gobierno para
inspeccionar la zona y las labores de
búsqueda continúan para los familiares
el temor aumenta con el paso de los días
Pérdida total entonces devastación
familiares todavía desaparecidos
no sabemos si debajo de estos escombros
puedan haber todavía personas para
evaluar los daños el presidente Nicolás
Maduro visitó la zona y aseguró que el
gobierno entregará nuevas viviendas a
quienes perdieron sus hogares hemos
visto destrozos Pues centenares de casas
destrozadas Pérdida total centenares de
casas y negocios con pérdida parcial yo
le digo al pueblo de tejerías al pueblo
de aragua cuenten con todo el apoyo del
gobierno humanista y bolivariano que
presido
en medio de un luto nacional la sociedad
civil se organiza estudiantes ongs
deportistas entre otros recogen ayuda
para los cientos de damnificados que
dejó el deslizamiento
exportados del secretario general de la
ONU Antonio Gutiérrez aseguró que están
coordinándose con las autoridades
nacionales para brindar ayuda y
asistencia